Well,
I think one of the most more surprising
things,
and this is something that I'm be
following and blogging about it,
some of the reports that have come out
of the Pew Research Center,
um,
it in,
in these analysis,
they're looking at a,
what exactly are people talking about at
blogs and this new media ecosystem,
whether it's blogs,
whether it's independent media,
whether it's twitter or whether it's a
facebook,
where is that content coming from?
Uh,
in,
in one particular study that they looked
at,
they looked at the media ecosystem
surrounding a Baltimore,
Maryland.
Uh,
and in that study,
what they found is roughly on average,
90 percent of the topics that were being
talked about at blogs or other
independent media originated with
traditional news organizations in
particular.
Either the local newspaper,
the Baltimore Sun for the national
newspapers in their,
in their online version.
That tells me that,
um,
where a lot of,
a lot of people claim that the
traditional media is no longer relevant.
In fact,
we fundamentally rely upon the
traditional media,
the role of the traditional journalists
as an independent professional,
a news gatherer to inform ourselves.
And it's the fabric of what we discuss
online and without the traditional,
a traditional news,
that traditional news gathering process,
we really wouldn't have a lot of good
content.
I'm,
uh,
and we wouldn't have a lot of original
reporting,
uh,
elsewhere.
Um,
uh,
online.
Uh,
the other really interesting thing is,
um,
uh,
more recently they looked at the major
blogs and they looked at an analysis of
the major blogs,
public affairs related blogs,
and they looked at what those blogs are
discussing and where the links are going
to m and a and more than 90 percent of
the topics discussed in the links.
We're back to the traditional media.
Uh,
and that's also interesting because
people claim now that,
uh,
the blogosphere now,
has this ability to control the news
agenda.
Well,
that's not necessarily the case.
The blogs are still influenced and
they're still driven by what's being
reported.
The New York Times or on the broadcast
news or on the cable news networks or
political talk radio.
It's that they take that content and
they sometimes refocus it.
They redirected,
they shape that agenda to either be in a
certain ideological direction,
they might reframe the significance and
the information that's being reported
on,
or they might take the agenda,
the traditional media and focus in on
just a few topics,
uh,
whether it's a foreign policy climate
change or particular political scandal,
you know,
there's a couple couple a things to
think about,
uh,
when,
when you're considering a,
the tendency towards self self selection
itself,
exposure to different topics and public
knowledge.
One is that,
uh,
going back three or four or five
decades,
the 19 sixties when we've asked in
surveys,
quiz questions about the public's
knowledge of the most basic political
facts or the basic facts about issues
related to science or the environment.
Inevitably the public scores very low in
these fundamental a quiz,
a quiz like surveys about either public
affairs,
literacy or science literacy.
Um,
uh,
so that hasn't changed.
And in fact,
what we,
what we've seen over the last 15 years
is that public knowledge and public
scores and those types of questions
remain relatively relatively stable.
Um,
it's a question though,
whether that's the best measure of
public knowledge or of,
of,
of civic culture.
Um,
uh,
one of the things that we're seeing is,
is actually not necessarily a decline
in,
in basic public knowledge,
but a real problem at getting public
attention and in elevating public
concern about many different issues.
The environment is a great example where
climate change is a great example.
And,
and,
and this is a problem really
fundamentally have of choice.
It's the great paradox of the age of
engagement that today we have more
information choices about public
affairs,
politics,
science,
health,
medicine,
the environment than anytime in history.
Yet if you,
as a consumer of information or as a
member of the audience or an individual
lack of preference or a motivation to
engage with that a news and information
on a regular basis,
you can completely avoid that
information.
It,
it's not top of mind.
Um,
and it's,
it becomes that much more difficult than
to,
to really raise the type of political
will necessary to get things done in
this country on issues like climate
change,
immigration,
social security,
uh,
healthcare.
Uh,
you name the public problem.